everyone I know who's watched this has
been like oh my god I'm a certified
monster now after watching it right it
was walking back to glama with me in
joshing haste and say we're joined by
the co-writer
the director and the star of a star was
born Bradley Cooper thanks for having me
now is there anything you can't do
because I laughing this sounds like but
what like I mean I don't even know what
I can do all I know is that I love to
try and and that's all I can ask it
myself when you came to directing what
do you learn about yourself do you think
if you stay true to what it is you want
to do and you work as hard as you can to
do it then then you have a fighting
chance to execute it I think I learned
that you know with the the movie that
you saw yeah yeah and I had an emotional
breakdown so yeah is is the movie that I
wanted to make completely so that that
felt that feels very gratifying to be
able to it's one thing to have an idea
or inspiration but then all the work
that's involved and all the people that
give themselves to that that story it's
really it's also very moving I feel very
moved by it
I think what's amazing as well the cast
have been saying you create a real
family like vibe on sad does that come
easy to you because you have your own
family now as well I mean that comes
easy because I grew up in a great friend
yeah I mean I was very wonderful parents
and and I know what I what's gonna get
the best out of me as an actors if I
feel I'm in a safe environment and an
inspiring environment an environment at
the same time that I'm gonna be
terrified to go into because it's calls
upon a lot from me I think that's what's
so amazing about cuz when I watch it
back that it's just like the chemistry
between you two just comes alive and you
bow for just like magnets that you're I
just go straight to each of you when
you're on the screen all the time and I
actually feel that about the other
characters yeah I mean if like Dave
Chappelle comes on and you're just like
those two guys were talking on that
bench and I'm I'm right there yeah and
saying as Sam Elliott and in Andrew Dice
Clay that it was really um everybody
really brought it hard the way you've
dealt with addiction in this is a really
bold strong message how did you try to
get the pitch right of putting that for
it's tricky yeah
no yeah there are two things that I knew
that it was that I had to really crack
one was authentically all they give your
musician that you watch this movie and
you go oh okay that's real and then if
you have any any relationship to
addiction that you would also go that's
that's the story and yeah and it was
just a lot of work a lot of prep a lot
of thinking about it waiting to receive
the right way to shoot it you know
really yeah it was not a quick sort of
oh yeah you know it really was really
thinking about the best way to
cinematically tell that story I was at
Glastonbury when you before oh you were
now I'm region your as the Pyramid stage
yeah and no we lost it like when you
went onto that stage yeah
not sheer crowd yes it's going mental
yes you learn about being a frontman oh
that's a really good question I've never
had gotten that question I mean that
really is a good way cuz you're right
there's something different about what
you're in the front you know and like
acting it's that the more the the more
you're exposed the more you have to dig
deep to be authentic and that's the
thing that I find you know when you're
trying to oh what is the frontman person
need to be you're screwed and you just
have to really double down and be
completely present and just tell the
story that you want to tell in the song
and if you do that then I think that's
when you can you can gain the attraction
that that role does you know demands as
a front person in the band because it
was it comes from Lady Gaga as well as
obviously like supremist from women
herself you guys seems gotten the carry
okay what would be your dream do you act
with her how I never even thought of
that
yeah I mean I love the shallow oh yeah
it's amazing but that's him singing I
don't even know if I could do it now
honestly